[Music]
hello everyone
so at the end of the previous chapter on
material behavior we had
arrived at a closed system of equations
and what i am going to discuss next uh
as i have written down here
by mentioning the boundary conditions is
going to be an extremely important
discussion but i have to write down a
few
sentences okay and i think it will be
faster if i just
type it out so uh the first important
point that we have to note
is that at the end of the
previous chapter on material behavior
we had arrived at a closed system of
equations
okay we had arrived at a closed system
of equations
meaning that
the number of unknowns
and the number of equations they matched
okay the number of equations was uh
equal to the number of
equations this is an extremely important
point
okay so this is what we refer to as a
closed system of equations
however it is extremely extremely
important to note
that
these equations can be
utilized to solve various specific
physical situations
various specific uh physical situations
or various specific problems
uh only when proper boundary boundary
conditions are written
only when proper boundary conditions
that it's very specific
okay that are specific to that physical
situation
or to those physical situations uh
are mentioned okay so
the situation is like this that for
various
uh physical situations
our governing equations okay our
governing equations
they remain the same
but it is depending
on what boundary conditions we have
for that for that physical situation
that we are going to end up
with different solutions
if this is an extremely extremely
important point to note
okay so our governing equations remain
the same
but the boundary conditions are
different and it is based on those
boundary conditions that we end up with
different solutions
that are specific to the problem now
uh these boundary conditions
uh they can be specified in a number of
different ways
okay we can specified over the
in the surface of the body uh
the body under consideration uh in
different ways
so the first way
is the first way is that uh
over the entire surface of the body we
have the traction specified
so over the entire surface of the body
fractions are specified
next we have that
over the entire surface
of the body uh it is the displacements
that are specified okay
and it can also happen that we can have
a mixture of the two
okay uh so maybe so
over a part of the surface
or a part of the surface maybe tractions
are specified
and over the uh rest of the surface
displacements are satisfied
are specified so it can happen uh
in these different ways so
diagrammatically
what is uh usually done is to represent
this in this fashion
that suppose we have this kind of a
general three dimensional body
so it is so these arrows they represent
various tractions uh acting on the body
okay so these are the various fractions
so this is the first case
uh the second case is where the
displacements are
specified so there we have again this
three-dimensional body
but now
but now over this entire surface some
kind of
displacement boundary conditions are
specified okay
so here i this dotted line means that
the displacement from this original
position to this thing this dotted line
that is specified it could happen as
this very special case and a very very
common case
that those displacements are specified
to be zero okay that is also very common
i mean that is quite the common case
and number three uh we have this general
body
such that over a certain part of the
surface maybe from this part to this
part
we have the specification of fractions
like this
okay so over this
entire part uh represented by this
double
line i have the specification of the
tractions and over the rest of the body
so over this i have
the displacements that uh specified
okay so again this dashed line
it represents the displacement so this
is the third case so that's how it is
represented
diagrammatically now let's see
how we can how how these things
can be actually represented
mathematically
uh using all the things that we have
been discussing till now
okay so as our first example uh
we'll take this kind of a situation
so we have a
example of boundary conditions okay
example
so we have this kind uh this wall
and suppose we have
a beam like this okay or a slab like
this
and uh here
on this surface i have
some traction specified okay where
basically a
uniform force f is acting
so this is my wall here where the beam
or the slab is just clamped
and you also note that my that i'm
choosing my
coordinate axis in this fashion that i
have my
x-axis like this here
a flush with the bottom surface and my
y-axis here
okay flush with the wall
and let's say that the
the length of this beam or slab
is a and let's say the
the height of this thing is
is b okay so this will help us these
geometric parameters will help
us in in a very specific uh or in
the specification of the boundary
conditions so let's take the
uh take the various edges of this
geometry
one by one so first of all we are going
to take the h
on the right so that is represented by x
equal to
a so at x equal to a
and we are going to do this in a very
systematic uh
fashion so what we'll do is we'll just
start out with this general
uh cautious relation okay so where t is
equal to
uh
sigma transpose very generally writing
this r
dot n and you know that the sigma
transpose is equal to sigma
okay now this basically will
uh comes out as
tx is equal to
sigma xx nx
plus sigma xy
ny and ty
is equal to sigma x y
n x plus sigma
y y n y i am not going to go into the
detailed discussion of how we
go from here to here okay so based on
our previous discussions you should be
right
able to write this or you should be able
to figure this out uh
very quickly now when we are talking
about the edge x
equal to a you note what is this tx
okay so this is the f is the uh
it is like the force per unit area uh if
it's not the direct the force okay so
this tx
this is going to be f itself okay
now you note that at x equal to a what
is nx and what is
ny nx is basically the x component
of the not the unit outward normal and
that is nothing but
1 and this ny is nothing but
0 so what we have from here
is basically that f is equal to
sigma x x which is very intuitive okay
but we have
arrived at this in a systematic fashion
e y however
is 0 and again n x is 1
and y is 0 because we are still talking
about the same surface
so this gives us basically this 0 is
equal to
sigma xy okay so that is the first set
of boundary conditions
uh applied on the edge x equal to a
next let us go to the top surface that
will be given by the
by y equal to b at y
equal to b what do we have
so we can do a similar sort of thing we
can start out like this
we can write the t x and t y and now you
know that on the top surface here
the tx is going to be equal to zero
and the t y is also going to be equal to
zero
all right so uh however
on that top surface what we need to note
is that the
n x this time that is going to be 0
and the n y that is going to be 1
ok so i can write this here also so n x
is equal to 1 here
and n y is going to be 0
this is very important so
if we do a similar sort of thing then
what we'll obtain
from the t x equation is that 0 both t x
and t y are 0 for y equal to b
so t x equal to 0 that is equal to sigma
x x n x
plus sigma x y and y that is going to
give me
sigma x y as 0
next for the t y
i have this thing 0
and sigma x y n x
that is zero because n x is zero and
sigma yy will be left
because n y this time is one
okay so we have sigma x y equal to zero
and sigma y y equal to zero
next uh for the
edge y equal to zero that is the bottom
surface
okay so
at y equal to 0
what we have again is
an x equal to 0 but n y
this time is equal to minus 1. okay
so let's let's do this
a little more a little more
systematically compared to y equal to b
so what we'll again have is uh dx
is equal to sigma x
x and x plus sigma
x y and y e
x is zero so also is t y uh
n x is zero and y
is minus one note it doesn't really make
a difference because t x happens to be
zero
so we actually end up with sigma x y is
equal to zero
next add sorry
i have to complete the the y part t y
is equal to sigma
x y n x
plus sigma y y and y
and again n x is equal to 0 and y is
equal to minus 1
because we are talking about the surface
at the bottom surface where the unit
outward normal is pointing opposite to
the y direction
so again t y is zero here so overall
what we'll have
is sigma y y is equal to zero
and finally for uh at uh
at x equal to zero so basically we are
talking about
this edge okay the edge which is clamped
to the
wall so for that it is very easy as you
can easily see
uh the only two conditions that we need
to
impose over that entire edge is that
both the x component of the displacement
represented by this u
that is 0 and
v is equal to 0 we don't need any other
condition here
so we did not specify anything here in
terms of the fractions
it is important to note that
when we have the the boundary conditions
specified in terms of the displacements
we don't have them represented in terms
of fractions and when we have them
represented in terms of fractions
we don't have them represented in terms
of displacements
so let us take another example uh
go to the next page
uh so we considered a
[Music]
situation like this
so
this is our wall again and we again have
a structure
which is clamped to the wall
but which has a triangular shape like
this
okay so
which is this kind of a triangular shape
so this is our wall here
now uh the loading on this
is acting in the vertically downward
direction here
now because we have these straight
edges it will be convenient if we set up
our coordinate axis
along those directions okay and what
we'll do is
we'll set up our y-axis like this
at this corner and we'll set up
our x-axis like this so flush with the
top edge
let's let's name the vertices
so this this vertex is a
this is b and this is c
okay so now we want to write down the
boundary conditions for these
different edges so first of all let us
take the edge
a b
so at y
equal to 0 you please note that this top
edge here
that is the y equal to 0 because the y
is pointed downward here
okay so for that first of all we note
that nx is equal to 0
and ny here is -1
this is very very important okay please
do not make a mistake here
because the y is pointed downward here
uh
this top surface the unit outward normal
to it
will be like this pointing upward here
but that upward direction
is the negative one okay so please don't
make a mistake
there so again just like before we are
going to write down the two different
components of the traction
in the previous example we had uh
although i did not mention it
we implicitly considered this to be true
that to be a two dimensional problem
similarly here we are considering this
to be
a two dimensional problem i mean our
ideas can very much
very easily be extended to three
dimensional but for learning purposes i
think it's cleaner
to talk about these two dimensional
examples first
so we have just like before this t x is
equal to
sigma x x n x uh plus
sigma x y and y
now note that this t x here the x
component of the traction on this top
surface a b
that is zero the n x is zero
the n y is minus 1 okay
so we actually have 0 is equal to minus
of sigma xy but
we don't need to use that minus
next for the y component we have t
y is equal to sigma x y
n x plus sigma y y
and y again this n x is 0
and y is minus 1 but please note that
this ty what is this okay so
ah i have not specified it here but you
can understand that this will have
this will be like a f or some p whatever
so this t y is this f or is it
minus n this is very important to note
okay
so please note that e y is
actually oriented along this y direction
okay now you don't
confuse yourself with the unit outward
normal
the t y uh the positive direction
of the positive convention of the t y is
very much pointing downward
and the applied load represented by
these blue arrows
they are also are represented by this f
okay this force per unit area f and so
this one will be very much
f
which means and this is interesting here
that we get
sigma yy is equal to minus
f this is very important to note because
you note
that suppose you were to take a little
element here
okay suppose you have to take a little
stress element here
and if we zoom into that that stress
element
even though our y is pointing downward
this sigma yy component here
by the positive convention would be very
much pointing upward
and because it is pointing upward it
makes sense for this final
result of our or the final
representation of our boundary condition
there in the y direction
to be represented in terms of the minus
f okay
so i i urge all of you to
be absolutely honest with yourself while
you are trying to understand this
okay take a take some time to really go
through this
in detail think about it very hard okay
and convince yourself
that this result that we have obtained
the sigma yy is equal to minus f
is indeed the correct uh representation
of the boundary condition there
next let us go to the edge bc okay so
this is the interesting thing here
the bc which is tilted now although it
is tilted
the uh the good thing about it is the
slope of this line is a constant because
it's a straight line
okay this is not a curved is not a
curved
kind of line here so because it's a
straight line
the no matter which point we look at the
unit outward normal is not going to be
as easy as
uh as this edge or this edge at the
stoppage
uh so both the nx and the ny components
will be non-zero
they will have some value but they'll
have a constant value all along this bc
so that's the important thing to note
here
so uh let's write down
the boundary conditions for the edge bc
so along
bc okay
so along bc again we'll have uh so this
time we
we cannot write that uh n x is equal to
zero and y equal to zero so both n x
and n y ah they will be non zero that
much i can write
okay so there will be so
some cos theta and sine theta okay
uh based on what angles angle is
specified here
so or here doesn't matter
you can figure that out
the important thing to note here is that
this general equation which we have been
using time and negan in the previous
example as well as
in this example the tx as sigma x n x
plus sigma x y and y that remains
undisturbed
uh furthermore you note
that this t x is actually zero here
okay it is zero because you note
that suppose we
suppose you think of a fraction of
it of a fraction vector here in this
fashion
at this point suppose you think of it
like this then this fraction vector will
have
one y component and one x component okay
so it will have
a y component like this and will have a
x component like this
it may be not so long uh
maybe like this okay now uh
it is very important to note that
because this particular traction vector
is 0 because we do not have any loading
on this that is why
both the ty component which is
represented by this
dotted vertically pointing downward
arrow and this leftward pointing dotted
arrow both of them
that is the tx and this is the ty they
are zero
okay so
that's how this is zero and none of this
is zero so
they remain similarly the t y
[Music]
this is going to be turned out uh is
going to be zero
let's write this down
okay we can't say anything more about
the right-hand side so
one thing uh good about here is that we
do know the nx value we do know the ny
value we do know the nx value we do know
the ny value there will be some finite
values
depending on what angles are specified
here okay the angle acb
or the angle abc or something will be
specified there or the lens will be
specified so we know
uh we know the values okay
uh
next uh along the line ac
okay along ac or i can write this as ac
or equivalently i can write this as
x equal to a so if you can imagine that
this length is this length is
a
okay so at x equal to a
what we'll have just like before is u
equal to zero
and b equal to zero so both the x and
the y
components of the displacement they are
zero
okay now it will be very very
interesting for you to think
what could perhaps happen if we have
some kind of a curved line here
so instead of this kind of a nice
triangular shape
suppose we have another example here
like this
suppose our wall is like this
and the stoppage is like this but
suppose
our bottom edge is like this then what
well you have to realize then and
suppose our loading remains unchanged
okay
so our loading is like this vertically
downward just like before
but now because of this kind of an edge
we have to understand
that at every point the values of nx and
ny
are going to change so as we move along
this curved line
the values of nx and ny they are going
to
change unlike this bc here where this nx
and ny
they were constant okay so nx and
ny values are constant here
okay so along this uh
the nx and ny
values will be known if you know the
equation of this
of this curved line but these values
are not constant this is very important
all right now
as a final example of
something a little bit more advanced uh
what happens
if we do not have this kind of uh so if
we just
quickly take a look we don't have this
kind of a free surface
or this kind of a surface on which
directly some loading is
acting rather we have we have
suppose an interface like this
where on one side you have one material
and on another side you have
another material what happens on this
kind of a boundary
okay so this is uh so this is an example
uh so suppose you consider and this is a
very very
uh common consideration that you have
what is referred to as a perfectly
bonded interface
so when you have a perfectly bonded
interface so it is like these two
these two so you understand that here
you have a bulk of a material
two here you have the bulk of the
material one and they are
maybe glued or pasted together by a very
good
adhesive okay so that bonding is
referred to as a perfectly bonded okay
so there is no relative motion
between the two okay so
what are the boundary conditions that
need to be specified there
well uh this is a very general kind of
thing
and you have to understand that in such
a general problem
your bound your x and y axis
will be in some general fashion like
this
okay so what is done here
is to set up at any generic point here
a local unit outward normal like this
and another axis
which is tangent to this
to this curve at that point okay so this
this line is tangent to that okay so
this is referred to as the s axis
okay so s is along the surface and n
is along the normal so this is like the
local coordinate axis which helps us to
specify
the boundary conditions and the exact
specification of the boundary conditions
is done in this fashion
so uh what is done
is uh physically what is done
is to ensure that
uh both the
displacements okay both the
displacements
and the tractions are continuous so we
write that down
that for a perfectly bonded interface so
both
the displacements
and the tractions are considered to be
continuous
okay so uh
we could i mean write a general theory
for this or write the general
representation of this
but i think it makes more sense to take
a little example like this so suppose
you have
a
an annular composite cylinder kind of
situation where
so this is the inner cylinder uh annual
annular cylinder and this is
another another material
or another outer cylinder here okay so
let's say this is
made of material two and this is made of
the material one
then what happens on this interface okay
that
the interface like uh between the two
so what we have to ensure is that and
suppose you consider that this is very
axis symmetric situation okay so there
is no variation along theta direction
there is a perfect circle and so on and
so forth so basically what is done is
that
the radial displacement is considered to
be equal here
uh if you're looking uh from this side
or if you're looking at that side
so what is done is that the value of the
displacement
okay let's say the radial displacement
is represented by this you
are the radial displacement at this
okay so let's say at the interface that
is
equal to the radial displacement
for the material 2 at the interface
okay but this is not enough you
also have to write down the uh
the equivalent uh traction
conditions so from those traction
conditions what you will obtain
is that sigma rr
is at the interface
okay from this side from the side of
looking from the side of the material
one that is equal to sigma
rr2 looking from the side of the
interface
and you can also think about
okay so think about what what will
happen
think about the other components the
other uh
other shear components so sigma
the other component will be sigma r
theta here
and uh
and sigma are said okay so in a very
general situation
i want you to think about this thing
okay and uh
we will in all likelihood take up
examples of this
uh once we go into the 2d elasticity
chapter
so with this we'll close this discussion
of uh of the boundary conditions uh
and we'll next go on to uh
to a discussion of the 2d elasticity
okay and that's where uh
our applied elasticity part with really
the applied part of the blood elasticity
will really come into
the picture so with that let me close
this discussion
thank you very much